[Music]
[Applause]
at the edge of the world in the dead of
the night a lighthouse looms over the
ocean and a body lies curled such a
Sinister sight guts and Gore on the
shore no es
scoti with that blood cing cry or the
innocent sigh of a child well it rattles
your soul as the dark takes control it's
enough to drive you wild when you're a
creature of the night all alone in the
black feel your sanity crack a creature
of the night do your demons reside in
the side that you hide from the
light your creature of the
night this eal Lighthouse flashed by the
ti live triplets whose mother
suspiciously died and suspects uncanny a
conable a nanny do they all have secrets
to hide how detective my objective is
follow the clues someone's tale is the
truth I don't yet know who was the
mother all there mentally died
accidentally or is there a killer I have
to
accuse in the storm this helps you
Ste surrounded by Shadows Shadow what
monsters might appear
mon when a creature of the
night R go so
insane night in the Bon you cold as the
madness takes hold see the blood drip
drip drip while your grip starts to slip
do your demons reside in the side that
you hide from the light are you a
creature the is a
creature of
[Music]
theature
the creature of the
[Music]
[Applause]
nighto